welcome back to CBS mornings and first
something you already know for the past
two decades more people have used Google
to explore the internet than any other
search engine and of course telling
people to Google it well that is part of
our everyday vocabulary but now that
dominance could be challenged by
breakthroughs in artificial intelligence
Microsoft has unveiled some of the most
powerful AI ever made public just
yesterday and it's incorporating that
into its Bing search engine and also its
Edge web browser we got to visit the
company's headquarters before that big
announcement for a never-before-seen
demonstration of this new technology and
we also spoke with Microsoft CEO Satya
Nadella about the future of AI and what
he says about an AI copilot for all of
us
we come to Microsoft to see what all the
talk is about this new technology that
could apparently reinvent the way you
use the web what are we looking at we
are looking at the brand new Bing and
With a Little Help from Divya Kumar our
Bing marketing executive we see this
really is something different it's
looking across the web
pulling in the collective knowledge that
it has and it's synthesizing and
Distilling the answer right along with
the usual search results we also get a
summary written by Microsoft's new AI
powered Bing can we ask it a follow-up
question absolutely and in a new feature
simply called chat the system turns even
complex questions into conversational
answers look at that
wow a complete multi-part personalized
calculation of my gas cost for example
for a family road trip that's amazing
and Microsoft is building chat into its
edge browser as well offering users a
tool that can summarize and even analyze
something as complex as a warranty for a
major appliance it says I'm sorry to
hear that your washer is not working
unfortunately using dish soap in your
washer may not be covered under the
warranty as it could be considered
misuse or abuse of the product which it
definitely would be and I'm going to do
generate it's a kind of co-pilot as
Microsoft puts it something that can
help you write it's not wonderful
honestly it's at the level of a lot of
food magazines or even launch a full job
search finding companies that are hiring
dear hiring manager and writing the
cover letter too it's a great starting
point hello Tony how are you it's great
to meet you for Microsoft CEO Satya
Nadella it's all a generational chance
to put his company back on top when it
comes to innovation we clearly are in a
kind of arms race when it comes to AI it
seems like everybody is coming out with
new products this year where is this
going
well as you said it's a new race and
it's a new race and the most important
software category or the largest
software category in search uh let's
face it uh Google dominates it we are
thrilled to be here logic Bing to
compete Microsoft developed the
technology in partnership with open AI
the creators of the viral sensation chat
GPT but while the new Bing is much more
powerful than its predecessor it's also
far from perfect that didn't work we
notice at times it can be slow and
unresponsive and on at least two
occasions it seems to not only get
things wrong but make things up but this
one's a little bit weird North
Carolina's in the wrong direction first
it suggests to stop in Dunn North
Carolina 500 miles out of our way when
we ask for guidance on a drive from New
York to Cape Cod we tell Bing that
doesn't work oops you're right I'm sorry
for the mistake I have to say done
connection and that's actually really
valuable feedback look at that amazing
or so it seemed until we later
discovered that the restaurant
definitely isn't in done Connecticut
because Dunn Connecticut does not exist
and we are amazed at how quickly it
suggests a job for a plumber in
Charlottesville Virginia Dutton Plumbing
45 bucks an hour sounds pretty great but
once again we later find no record of
any Dutton Plumbing in the area can we
ask it can I trust you in fact as the
bot readily admits this generation of AI
is not yet to be trusted I sometimes
make mistakes it warns us double check
the facts is this ready are you
confident for wide release
the only way for any new technology is
to be really perfected is to be in the
market with real human feedback if
anything is in particular with AI it has
to get aligned with human preferences
both personally and societally in terms
of the norms and that's why we want to
launch it we want to have all the safety
we want to have all of the things that
will make sure that no harms are created
but we need it out there in the real
world we had hoped to test how the new
search handles the risk of
misinformation and bias but that's when
an off-camera executive stepped in I
would say that's probably not the best
thing in our beta that we're running
today he asked us to leave the entire
topic of guard rails to their CEO who
told us the model had been trained with
safety as a top priority so if you ask
it to help you do something illegal what
are you saying it will not and and if it
does we will immediately do take down
another concern is is bias how can you
even begin to control or police that
in chat well I mean it's the same thing
again in today when you search on the
web you get what's available on the web
you know this is where human agency is
at a premium you will always be able to
trip any new AI model uh because you
prompted it so I think we start with the
responsibility each of us as users have
to take and yes we will have many many
mechanisms to ensure that nothing biased
nothing harmful gets generated and then
I have to ask and I sound a little bit
silly I feel a little bit silly even
contemplating it but some very smart
people ranging from Elon Musk to Sam
Altman who I just saw in the hallway
here your partner at open AI have raised
the Specter of AI somehow going wrong in
a way that is lights out for Humanity
you're not in your head you've heard
this too yeah is that a real concern and
if it is what are we doing look I mean
look runaway AI is if it happens it's a
real problem and so the way to sort of
deal with that is to make sure it never
runs away and so that's why I look at it
and say so let's start with before we
even talk about alignment and safety and
all of these things that one should do
with AI let's talk about the context in
which AI is used I think about like the
first set of categories in which we
should use these powerful models or
where humans unambiguously
unquestionably are in charge and so as
long as we sort of start there
characterize these models make these
models more safe and over time much more
explainable then we can think about
other forms of usage but let's not have
it run away the car of humanity is at a
Crossroads to the left is dystopia to
the right is Utopia the blinker is on
which way is it pointing it's Utopia
he's excited and I know I I believe him
I share that excitement as well I think
there's an amazing opportunity here but
they know that this thing is still got
some Kinks to work out and what they're
doing actually is inviting the public to
get on board try it test it and that
will actually make it better so people
can sign up for Early Access and I think
they should this is very interesting and
that's why I applaud Microsoft and
Nadella in particular I know him to be a
smart thoughtful really compassionate
leader because most companies won't let
you come in and see as they're working
out the Kinks to say come on in and show
it to you and say look we're still
working on I found that very fascinating
I'm gonna have to take back my yikes
yeah because I think I I found that so
interesting and so fascinating yeah now
I got to say to your point of runaway AI
I'm glad it's not perfect yeah yeah
right like I'm cool with it not being
perfect but what I saw and what you
showed us today I mean that's impressive
yeah nothing's perfect in the beginning
they're always Kinks right they're
always right always of course yeah not
usually this big I mean making up a town
in Connecticut is a pretty big deal uh
but you know people should just be aware
where when they're using this it's going
to sound authoritative and it's coming
from Microsoft you're going to want to
trust it but it's telling you don't
trust it so when you ask it for medical
advice don't believe it at first you
know when the financial advice be
careful we're at a stage where this is
the future but the future is not ready
for us yet
very fast I was eye-opening thank you
for that he gives very few interviews
how did you get that Tony I think it's
because you get okay no I don't know it
definitely wasn't because of me yeah
definitely wasn't because of me you know
we do a very good job on this show of
explaining complex things this is a
brand new day and I think we laid it out
for people yeah that was fascinating to
watch thank you for that